we've got a little info on how it's all
working out for CNN at the moment this
is from Forbes February marked CNN's
lowest rated month in a decade with the
Network's Prime Time lineup dropping 42
percent among viewers 25 to 54. the key
demographic group valued by advertisers
compared to the same month one year ago
for full day ratings Fox News easily won
the month with an average of total
audience of 1.437 million viewers down
14 from a year ago followed by MSNBC 711
000 viewers down just one percent and
CNN 474 000 viewers down 24
CNN's struggling Morning Show CNN this
morning averaged 360
000 total viewers and just 73 000
viewers in the key demo in February the
show's lowest rated month since it
launched last fall the show debuted in
November ratings to lower than the show
it had replaced new day and has failed
to make much traction since then with
critics note noting that instead of
chemistry the hosts Caitlyn Collins Don
Lemon and Poppy Harlow often talk over
each other the show also suffered from
lemon making sexist comments in a
discussion about Republican presidential
candidate Nikki Haley's age saying Haley
isn't in her prime because at 51 women
are considered to be in their Prime in
their 20s and 30s and maybe 40s lemon
apologized off air but his remarks LED
CNN chief executive Chris Licht to tell
staff I sat down with Don and had a
Frank and meaningful conversation lick
said an internal memo he has agreed to
participate in formal training as well
as continuing to listen and learn we
take this very seriously Flash Forward
to months and Don Lemon tweeted this
I was informed this morning by my agent
that I have been terminated by CNN I am
stunned after 17 years at CNN I would
have thought that someone in management
would have had the decency to tell me
directly at no time was I given any
indication that I would not be able to
continue to do the work I have loved at
the network it is clear that there are
some larger issues at play with that
said I want to thank my colleagues and
the many teams I've worked with for an
incredible run they are the most
talented journalists in the business and
I wish them all the best and within
moments of that statement CNN had to
refute him because that was fake news
here's from CNN comes Don lemon's
statement about this morning's events is
inaccurate he was offered an opportunity
to meet with management but instead
released a statement on Twitter so again
guys I want to connect to what's going
on here we are seeing alternative
platforms blow up we are seeing that you
the consumer has a little bit of clout
by making choices yourself because if
you start doing it then other people
start doing it and then what happens Bud
Light loses money and new beers will be
out there or people will drink tequila
perhaps or whatever it else might be you
stop watching CNN and stop swallowing
their propaganda and then the
propagandists like Brian stelter and Don
Lemon actually get fired and it all
starts burning down this is good this is
all good
foreign
[Music]